>> THANK YOU.
MIKE: NOW LET’S TURN TO A
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN.
MEMBER OF HOUSE OVERSIGHT AND
REFORM COMMITTEE.
MARK DESONJA, MEMBER OF HOUSE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, WELCOME.
>> THANKS, MIKE FOR HAVING ME.
MIKE: YOU’VE SEEN THE VIDEOS
FROM REPUBLICAN AND COMING FROM
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
PUT OUT VIDEO.
HOW DOES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GET A HANDLE ON
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
>> ALL OF US IN CONGRESS NEED TO
TAKE A DEEP BREATH, REALIZE THIS
HASHAS GONE THROUGH MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
THE RIGHT THING.
BORDER IS CLOSED.
DON’T COME HERE.
WE NEED TO CREATE MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE WE
MANAGE IT PROPERLY.
MIKE: SHOULD THE PRESIDENT GO TO
THE BORDER, SIR?
>> I THINK IT IS GOOD FOR ALL OF
US TO GO TO THE BORDER.
I HAVEN’T BEEN IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS.
I’M ANXIOUS TO GO AGAIN.
I’VE BEEN THERE MANY TIMES IN
THE PAST.
THIS IS A CRISIS MANUFACTURED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE NEED IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT
SECURES OUR BORDER.
MIKE: DO YOU HAVE HOPES OF
GETTING SOMETHING DONE IN
CONGRESS?
IMMIGRATION REFORM HAS BEEN A
TOUGH ISSUE TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE AS YOU KNOW?
>> WE HAVE TWO BILLS IN THE
HOUSE.
WE SENT MULTIPLE ONES OVER IN
THE LAST SESSION, THAT WE THINK
WILL WORK BUT REPUBLICAN
SENATORS HAVE TO JOIN US, GIVEN
THE FILIBUSTER.
SO IT IS REALLY UP TO THEM.
MIKE: OKAY.
TO SOMETHING THAT IS NEAR AND
DEAR TO YOUR HEART.
I KNOW YOU ARE INVOLVED WITH
GROUND TRANSPORTATION, ALSO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE UPCOMING
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE AND DO
YOU WANT BUY-IN FROM YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, SIR?
>> WELL LATTER PART, YES.
I’M A FORMER REPUBLICAN.
I REGISTERED TO VOTE I WAS A
REPUBLICAN WHEN I FIRST ELECTED
TO THE CITY COUNCIL YEARS AGO
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I WAS A REPUBLICAN.
I LEFT BECAUSE WHAT I SAW IN THE
PARTY.
YES, WE WANT THEIR SUPPORT.
THIS IS A TRANSFORMATIVE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BUT PARTICULARLY
FOR WORKING AMERICANS.
IT WILL PUT WORKING AMERICANS TO
WORK WITH GOOD PAY FOR MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS, IT WILL HELP THE
OVERALL ECONOMY.
MIKE: SHOULD IT BE STRICTLY
INFRASTRUCTURE OR DO YOU WORRY
ABOUT IT BECOMING A CHRISTMAS
TREE WITH ALL OTHER KINDS OF
GOODIES BEING ADDED ON?
>> IT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT REMEMBER
INFRASTRUCTURE CONNECTS LOTS OF
THINGS PARTICULARLY NEW ENERGY
SOURCES WHICH I’VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOR A LONG TIME.
WE NEED TO CREATE, NEW
RENEWABLE, SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
SOURCES.
WE’RE DOING IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS HELPING OUR ECONOMY.
SO, YES, INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST.
BRIDGES, ROADS, RAILS BUT THOSE
ARE CONNECTED TO OUR ENERGY
SOURCES PARTICULARLY HOW WE
LIVE.
MIKE: I WANT TO PLAY A CLIP FROM
YOU FROM TRANSPORTATION SET TEAR
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
I WILL ASK YOU TO RESPOND.
>> IF WE BELIEVE IN SO-CALLED
USER PAYS PRINCIPLE YOU PAY FOR
ROADS BASED ON HOW MUCH YOU
DRIVE.
GAS TAX USED TO BE ON JUST WAY
YOU DO IT, IT IS NOT NOW.
THE VEHICLE MILEAGE TAX COULD BE
A WAY TO DO IT.
MIKE: CONGRESSMAN, DO YOU AGREE?
>> THAT IS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
I CHAIR THE TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
I WAS FIRST AUTHOR OF FIRST EM
T-BILL HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS A POSSIBILITY.
THERE ARE EQUITY ISSUES WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT, VIS-A-VIS PEOPLE
HAVE TO TRAVEL 2 1/2 HOURS EACH
WAY TO GET TO WORK.
BUT THOSE THINGS I THINK WE CAN
GET TO WORK.
MIKE: ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC THERE
WILL BE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE END ON INFRASTRUCTURE?
DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE
TO DO IT ON THEIR OWN?
>> I’M OPTIMISTIC BY NATURE JUST
LIKE PRESIDENT BIDEN BUT IF WE
CAN’T, IT IS TOO MUCH OF AND
YOUR AGAIN SY WE NEED TO GO
AHEAD.
WE SHOULD LISTEN.
I WOULD SAY, I DON’T AGREE WITH
SENATOR BRAUN PREVIOUS GUEST ON
ALMOST EVERYTHING, WHEN THEY DID
THE TAX CUT FOR THE WEALTHY THEY
DIDN’T CONSULT US AT ALL EITHER.
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER BUT
BOTH SIDES HAVE TO TAKE A STEP
TOWARDS EACH OTHER.
SO FAR I HAVEN’T SEEN THAT FROM
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
MIKE: CONGRESSMAN MARK